welcome to this video this is coverage
of the second sink filled cup named
after rex sinquefield the yeah the
mastermind behind the san luis and chess
club and scholastic center he some
started this tournament last year and it
was a very strong tournament last year
but this year the sum in terms of rating
is the strongest tournament ever oh it's
difficult with those kind of best ever
and so on especially when it comes to
rating averages where is not totally
clear how this some increase of rating
points over the yeast is to be a how
this is to be a calculated is this a
real increase of strength noise there's
some mathematical thing behind it that
ratings get higher and higher
nevertheless this is a super strong
tournament we have basically yeah only
super top players we have cars and
playing Aronian Kara wanna Nakamura to
par loaf and Michaella graph I'm not a
frequent name in the super top events
but the top French player has reached a
very high rating 2768 and is also known
for his enterprising starts oh great
great tournament edition let's see what
happened in the first round i'm doing a
daily coverage of all the rounds so
mostly a um will be a usually a couple
of hours after the the round is finished
simply because the round normally
finishes after midnight european time
and well in the past i tried to do video
at that time but it it was always some
but did be difficult i was usually very
tired and had a hard time to make them
until to make good analysis and and
proper video so i rather do it the
following day my tongue
I will cover all games two games around
with slight slight annotations only and
one game a little bit more in detail
let's start with the first round we have
our own Ian plain white against Nakamura
and of all three games this was the
comparatively less interesting game on
least interesting game let's see what
happened Nakamura playing black and he
went for the sloth defense um he plays
all kinds of openings also this love
still a somewhat rare choice for him it
is of course a super solid opening and
we got to the so-called classical sloth
and the traditional main line of this
opening black is temporarily giving up
the center on c4 and in return has got a
super solid structure this is the line
with e3 sometimes called I think the
Dutch variation this is some I think
originated in them World Championship
match in the 1930s is it in the 30s
between over and Alec on when this was
played frequently ok we have all the
moves that are very very standard here
white has some some possibilities night
h4 queen bee three ton of moves some
queen e to us the main line black
castles and white goes for e four so we
have an interesting situation out of
them relatively classical opening d4 d5
we have reached a position where black
as giving up the center temporarily why
does got the ideal points here but black
has pressure against the center
combining a captcha on c3 with the night
and the bishop attacking you for white
has a hard time to maintain as pawns in
this ideal state you will probably have
to advance them especially the e45 I
mean and this is happening really
quickly here with e5 it's hard for white
to to avoid that also considering
that black him has the additional idea
to play 65 which can easily happen if
wide know places you remove you can play
Bishop f4 it's also possible it in this
case Aronian played be 595 and take
stakes and queen three Queen III is a
slightly ugly-looking move but it's
absolutely essential to get out of this
pin to make any headway here White has
the space advantage on the King side
with those ponds now it's very often the
case that your players pointed towards
the direction of the pawn chain so
what's pawn chain is directed here so he
will do something on the King site
because there's his face advantage um
black mostly relies on his very solid
structure is no pawn weakness whatsoever
and no squares are spectacularly week
it's also important for him to have the
be four square right has weakened as
Queen side um okay rook e8 this is a
useful move at make sure that if
necessary at night can come to f8 Bishop
d2 wants to exchange the slightly
annoying Bishop White's dark squared
Bishop is not great anyway and queen 85
yeah here is the slight wrinkle in this
game move order move on a thing or move
on is maybe the wrong expression a
slight subtle t.y place Queenie one here
normally they go like this and Queen to
e7 this for example is the main line in
the recently released book by top
Israeli Grandmaster and theoretician at
Boris of rock and he assesses this at
the end s about equal black very often
gets play on the on the C file and can
exchange with Bishop g610 exchanges his
bishop on on h5
in the game we have a very similar
position Queenie one takes takes Queen
d8 it's the same thing but the Queen's
on d eight instead of e7 this recently
has been played 95 normal way to go
attacking on age 7 and black gets his
Bishop to exchange here in a recent game
cuz in John off me back knee Bacchus the
top finish player 2600 strength when
Master on he cousin John off played the
Bishop to e2 keeping more pieces on the
board at the end term it did not lead to
very much it was a draw after after 48
moves black played the typical idea
night pata to ultimately maybe go to one
of the week dark squares on the the way
aronian played is a bit more typical he
took on g6 here we come to an important
moment um a moment that our move that is
very that's a very routine move for an
experienced player or player who has
some experience in this kind of
structure now camera here took with the
African it's that's as much totally
normal in this position but less
experienced player might take with Jesus
with the H porn and this is in fact much
much weaker the problem is that in this
situation it is very difficult to get
rid of the Jeep or at the g95 night as
f6 weakens everything yeah like II 6 g 6
and so on it's a very bad structure and
you have a hard time to accept this
night on g5 all the time that is not not
great here this night for black very
annoying piece so when F takes is much
better in this end this respect because
here you can easily get it out with h6
another problem with this situation is
if you imagine one thing GU k3 this is
the next
here white also besides the idea to
double on the C file he might also play
something like this rook h3 Queen f4 h4
and checkmate ya can easily happen and
this kind of idea would probably falls
back to play in the weakening f6 not
sure if the sea fowl play of root gauge
reads better but definitely H takes 26
is a strategical mistake so f takes
fairly normal and f4 yeah bullets during
the center and allowing the night to
retreat to f3 within the pawn chain yeah
black now initiates play on the
queenside with Queen B 62 Queen a6 he
always keeping an eye on their five
point I think basically in this game the
the state of around equal play was never
really a was never really changed I
think maybe at one point aronian hadn't
could have played a bit a bit more
ambitiously we will see that this is
happened and black has this counter play
on the queenside of course black is not
better because he always has this this
is only the pure lead offensive night on
a fade which he probably must keep their
to keep his weaknesses covered rooks
asleep and there was one situation here
the aronia played rook c8 here maybe
quincy 3 was still possible to try to
fight for a little bit of an edge this
with this idea where maybe we get to a
position where the C and B porn are
exchanged um let's say let's say
something like this one group c 1 just
jam to get this to get the structure
this is something where white can try to
to play on because of this space
advantage and black ants this slide
weakness only six it will in all
likelihood end in a draw anyway but this
is something that yeah if you if you
give cards and YTM it will be a very
long day in the
office not not much fun to play but
certainly with good drawing chances for
black and white is only a bit bit better
but after rook c8 we are now talking
about almost technically for straw rook
takes Queen see one queen a two and now
black has this big counter play on the
second rank against g2 white cannot take
here after the back he's going to get
checkmated not a good not good idea this
is better protecting on on g2 yeah
here's a little nice little trap but
easy to see if black no moves the night
watches the funny way to checkmate black
Versace life it it's quite nice the
Queen on h1 is not only a defensive
piece but the Nakamura of course saw
that and played Queen to a three yeah I
know white went back to see one quite
quite funny setting up this sort of pin
here and covering c8 everything's okay
Queen a to Queen h1 and this was the
perpetual in a way or the repetition
that in the end happened in this game to
finish it with the draw so looks like a
very solid correct draw Nakamura also i
think here if i read this right I'm
stated that he was yeah he said his plan
was to play a very solid sorry way a
solid game because he starts with two
blacks against aronian and then cards
and he wanted to to have some something
something in the books after or not
risking too much and then face maybe
cows and with black in the second round
after something bad happened around one
so i guess a very a very prudent
approach okay let's look at the next
game yeah the second game is to palo
Caruana yeah and this is a game of two
players who are who yeah we look back at
the very good results recently Caruana
I'm from a brief moment after the number
two spot in the world rating this is all
very close he's got 2801 well Aronian
has 2805 or something and that Apollo
had a very good oh lewb jet in tromso
norway he had the top result on the
first board for bulgaria so he should be
in good shape it seems let's see what
happens in this game to Palo place 90th
ricci for we have a English opening and
we have this line where black is playing
d5 taking over let's say the initiative
in the center um we have this we now
have this variation and to be honest um
I'm for for a long time for really a
long time I'm mystified while white
players choose this I mean I have
studied the English quite a lot because
I play Knight f3 for a very very long
time but I am I always I never
understand why white would play this
line it's basically on reversed maroc
see bind wear white has an extra tempo
well great but it's a it's not a very
great structure in any case I always
thought that why term is basically
conceding equality right from the start
but ok maybe my view there is a is a bit
term is a bit one-sided as I always like
to play the maracas see structures yeah
from the side who has the bind never
really liked to play against it
nevertheless we have fun some very
well-known moves this has been played a
ton of times um of course compared to
her maroc see here black has the
structure but has less active pieces in
the maraki bind very often black it's a
bit a bit more active like bishops not
on d 7 but maybe only six the Queen on d
7 it's all a bit quicker
let's say in your build up but
nevertheless it's a structure where
white has one very distinct problem he
has very little in terms of porn breaks
how is white going to do to break in
this in destruction he's got them my
definition here less space on the three
ranks against against for and what to
paula was trying is he's playing for f4
here with this maneuver alternatively it
seems that white can also play for b
form and the same at least in my mind is
a bit more a more interesting if you
want b6 before this has been tried
before i found two games en my my
database with this i mean maybe probably
they're more than two but two recent
games this is interesting the idea is
that is black now gives pawn grabbing
white is opening up the position with
deform and this is in fact quite quite
an active position for wide with some
compensation this is a case where why
it's a good development can really can
really help him he now manages to open
up the position i like this idea for
white black does not need to take he can
also play as something like that after
which white I'm played rukka c4 in a
recent game a game between anissa piano
and the player corner G notch I think
probably in part of beach' 2014 a recent
game in only played about one or two
month ago and white ended up winning
this after after some complication
interesting interesting way to play on
the weight Apollo is playing it is also
known the Knight to c4 and and f4 a
similar plan is also seen in the maroc
see with the f5 in the maroc see bind
this plan is normally not very good as
it weakens the structure quite a lot
here it is debatable on
because white has really much more piece
activity than in this colors reversed
positions black ass some slightly am
unlucky pieces here at night on sea to
win this pin it's all a bit black is not
perfectly coordinated but if like
manages to coordinate then in structure
will be simply good because those pawns
tend to be a liability in the long run
when if black manages a buildup on the
DAT file which is obviously quite a long
way to happen then those pawns can be a
problem the knight on d4 causes a strong
piece very often it can be kicked away
with the e3 but this further weakens
white structure so this is all about the
balance of peace activity and structure
I think however that relatively quickly
him to pull off some playing a gap a bit
strangely he now went to play G for
which from my chest taste is a very
weird move but okay he's obviously the
stronger player g4 is I guess designed
to ya gain some space he and probably
allow this idea it would be nice if you
if you get this actually in but it turns
out that this is not happening I mean
black is playing very precisely Bishop
you ate this should be one be five
kicking the night away and Bishop b6 and
that's it for Bishop g3 and now really
ask yourself what is the pond doing on
g4 besides weakening the the King
position and yeah I really absolutely
dislike White's position it feels very
uncoordinated to me the computer um if
you give this to the engine it only
gives black a very miniscule advantage
however I think in a practical game this
is very difficult to play already um you
don't really know exactly what white
should do is got lots of structural
weaknesses and no clear way to to attack
something the compounds to go on night
5 in this position this is what two part
of plate 9 f 5 with a line like this
mission here and then III and surface
this is about equal yeah maybe this is
true i mean i still definitely would
prefer black young and because long-term
white skin position is simply not not
very attractive and all this all this
looks look shaky in the long run however
it's not clear that black can't exploit
this in any way and quickly exploit this
um this is a certainly still and still
somewhat okay this move forever what
were to pile of played directly leads
into big big problems black black
exchanged no Bishop takes um young
knight takes looks maybe a bit more
natural but also runs into problems
after Bishop c6 black is already
threatening yeah nice little little
tactic not difficult to see but let's
say what goes here then black can't take
check here all the consequence of the g
forms something like this is of course
excellent for black yeah he took with
the bishop in our bishop f7 of course we
need to break this diagonal and prepare
night to d4 Knight f5 and Bishop b5
black has nicely centralized pieces the
bishop he is very strong and the night
will hope to deform note that if in this
position white I would have the porn on
g3 i think there's absolutely not much
going on yeah the this is simply am this
pawn would love to go backwards this is
at apollos mafia and it was a corona
afterwards stated that after Queen d2 he
felt that black will get an almost
decisive advantage yeah maybe this is
the case after Queen d2 black is very
very well a very very very very very
good shape something like bishop see
three years what the comp recommends
they're all relying by the way on
on this little thing um yeah after
Bishop c3 black probably will play g6
trying to get rid of the night and again
like it's certainly in good shape and
and to be preferred but it's not like
him he should win immediately a line
that shows the problem is is this where
should the night go now something like
this is very much yeah on the off side
and something like this runs into a very
awkward pin and again look at the King
here yeah this is what what was played
and now 90 force plate yeah this is a
super strong night Karen white no
exchanged and played played the look
yeah there was night be three simply
threatened so this is fork and now black
has a good coordination of pieces and
again it's the King position with the
porn on g3 it would be a yeah wouldn't
be a big deal black would be better but
nothing nothing too serious with that
white probably what could probably
defend their with your knife exchanges
took here check tween deform very strong
centralization check now getting the
Queen near the king yeah TM the
weaknesses are are too much there's also
this additional idea c5 to c4 and Kara
wanna goes to work right away who see
for the whole game was played almost
perfect there but like I think it's very
hard to to find any of any floor there
at least if you if you like like I did I
didn't have so much time of you check it
with your with your own brain hated
assisted by the comp you really don't
see what what black should do better
here to pull off plate plate Quincy to
rupee eight getting the rooks involved
yeah this is not helping very much this
capture but there really was no no big
alternative what tries to to play
something like this there is some there
is ruka d7 coming and just one
possibility let's look at this for
example takes takes takes Queen age
three and this is not not something that
white will be able to defend Bishop c5
he like has a very neat way to win
Bishop to deform very nice move rook
takes checkmate very cute and this check
here leads to a disaster with those dual
threats it's a the King position that
ultimately will cost white the game yeah
I now it's piled up on the evo III
should be 28 to power off resigned yeah
no no way to to defend this position if
we look at this the Queen as detect and
it has nowhere to go probably must go to
to f3 otherwise Queen h3 is coming at ya
like we'll just take and now he promotes
the hall so I'm very awkward looking
away a way in a very awkward looking
game on the white somehow he lost the
thread TM starting with with g4 I mean I
expressed my dislike for whites
opposition them before but this is a
personal preference i simply don't like
this type of position very much because
i don't really see what what great plan
i i have here versus white butt g4
ultimately backfired at least it it
would led to a position where white
could easily go astray and it happened
quickly here with this night 35 move
which does not look too bad at first but
it seems that in fact why does in big
trouble after that okay this was lost
for to pile up against karana now let's
check the world champion michela graph
against
card next let's see what happens we have
fun the Scotch game yeah always hard to
predict what rashi lagrave is going to
play or MV lses for him off of God it's
very long name so understandable um yeah
but the the Scotch isn't opening that
year that he plays sometimes and we have
this line with Bishop c5 cards in place
place this normally I believe I mean
there's also Knight f6 of course but um
this is his usual choice night be three
yeah this nowadays some has become
fashionable in early years night xe6 was
the main move for Queen f6 and this kind
of lights but it seems that black girl
has diffused this Muslim takes Knight f6
and now the interesting move here white
has multiple ideas and not only one move
playable here white plate Queenie to
this move in fact has been played also
by by Carlton um some years ago I think
it was two thousand I didn't look up the
exact game reference I think it was 2009
in Nanjing against back row not sure
about the name the other things
definitely right he played the 10 back
row and it was in Nanjing I think
2009-2010 I don't know but this is an
interesting move white intends to play
this should be three to exchange the b6
Bishop and quickly casts a long I'm
interesting to see what cars in place
now he placed them in a 5 a-5 is a very
rare when this position and I only found
one game where this was played between
volokitin and ayana off probably the
Ukrainian championships 2013 um an
interesting move the idea is to play
quickly
form or to provoke rights to play a for
himself in the game between volo kitchen
and ayana of in fact a four was played
and then night before was a black sir
Black's idea the point of this is the
this is insertion of those two moves
gives black the before square for the
night and the night on before is a
useful piece it always um yeah
threatened c2 is near the king if black
they've white castles long i did also
controls the GED five square that's very
important if we imagine that something
like that is happening in the game
Bishop g5 was played um h6 something
like that if you look at this structure
you see that 95 can be a good idea for
why trying to use this pin and now the
d5 square securely protected by the
before nine but so that's very nice in
the game vashi lagrave mvl he played
however and instantly played five which
is quite surprising as a five is really
a backwater it's not a very a lot of
unknown move as it turns out afterwards
in some interviews I think I think it
was Nakamura who said that Kasparov
showed him this move in in their
training sessions and probably also
showed cards in the move that this this
is interesting for black so it was it
was in a way known but never really
played yeah the first couple of Musa
were played very quickly cards now
castles quickly castles on terms of time
spent interesting the decision but
probably the only move you couldn't
really move the night and it's clear
that after the capture and white did
capture that the e-file is very
important Black has given up a piece
though a for first attacking this night
you know what should wise do now he
played the best move and and quickly
again this was this was sam and
lies beforehand by the way instead of a
4 which is logical and good there also
was rupee aid this was not totally silly
first inserting this and then play a
form now the point is that after 92
Black has this idea 94 queen d 1 and d 5
this is some compensation for luck
definitely it's not like it's totally
silly but black has given up a piece and
it is certainly not apparent that this
is enough for a piece it's however
interesting to analyze I continued a bit
but ultimately it should be probably
better for wide something like this is
saving the day I guess however a4 is
simple and good right now played 95 it's
clear that if Y to move the night the
black initiative will become very very
strong rookie eight now deform only move
and the very scary move to play d5 let's
say takes takes here and a 3 and here
black has a huge initiative it's a very
a very uncomfortable position for whites
to play and say rook t1 Queen f6 this is
very very well difficult to play but
definitely prefer black IAM and the
computer is giving black and almost
winning winning advantage already so
white probably must play this 95 rupee
aid this should be three not much choice
really and black regained his piece on
b3 yeah now whiter does not have much of
a choice he definitely wants to get out
of Queen out of the e-file and he does
so with tempo Queen g4 g6 Bishop c4 if
we look at the time spend and this is
pretty accurate I was seeing this in the
live broadcast Mahela brav even had more
time on the clock that at the beginning
of the game he dashed out
moves absolutely instantly to gain time
with this increment while Carlton has
spent a couple of minutes but still it
was clear that they both knew that this
is a valid way to play it wasn't a
surprise but how however here cards and
sank into deep thought he now spent more
than 30 minutes on his next move and
ultimately played the very
attractive-looking move night before
turns out that this is probably just the
best move and very often this is the
case of cars and really yeah Dick's down
deep in in a position he who very often
will play the best one the absolutely
best move and this is such a case very
funny looking move just putting the
night on pre but there is a very clear
logic behind that the knight on d5
always covers this very very annoying
porn on f6 that always can be the start
of some mating attack so we want to get
rid of the night and with night before
this is technically possible at least
them we can distract the night from from
d5 however blackhead alternatives it
seems that the move Bishop deform was
also possible this leads to very crazy
complications that are absolutely am
yeah difficult to assess even with
computer assistance very difficult to
assess the main line of of the computer
here is Queen edge for keeping this pawn
for the moment Bishop b2 and now just
castles why does a very very am ignorant
of hot black sir blacks bishop on b2 and
the ball on b3 but White's attacker says
quite strong here if black now is some
taking on a two first there is the funny
move c3 and white has excellent chances
here cutting off this Bishop from f6 and
introducing this idea again or renewing
this idea
this is an excellent position four ID if
black whoever takes the rook which seems
to be the best place be too now we come
to a position that it is very forced as
Queen age six is such a huge red black
must play wiki five to allow Queen evade
and here it's quite amazing this
sequence you read the Queen child leads
to a very unclear position the computer
is just saying okay well this is equal
um and this is still difficult for human
nerve human to to really comprehend
however if we look at this a bit more we
see that why does an exchange down but
he will get the B to pawn he has f6 and
this is a pawn that it's not so easily
won in the near future and he has a very
very active pieces the bishop on c8 for
example it's not playing at all while
whites Bishop and night are very active
it's a bit difficult here in this
analysis em without even continuing
further but it said quite clear white
hairs compensation and it seems that it
is enough compensation to to to to keep
this equal note that also this move can
easily happen to support the point if it
is attacked at some point um there were
many fascinating possibilities counting
at the end plate night before and it is
a very strong booth now Rashida graph
started to think and long almost 30
minutes I guess he ultimately decided to
take on before um wyd also could
consider to Castle but I think this is
probably the better choice and after
castles um there are also many many
ideas for black um some aggressive ones
some more solid ones black you can for
example play the very enterprising line
then here this looks a bit crazy but
it's interesting the III porn is very
weak it can be attacked for example by
this and the AC to pawn is quite an
annoying quite annoying unit that is not
so easily taken off the board very
unclear position possible to play but
difficult in a in a practical game to
decide upon um black also can play after
castles just d6 gaining this tempo on
the Queen and then something like like
this Queen h4 takes takes and here black
can take on c2 tough to play I know I'm
tough to play for human in a game this
looks very scary check but it seems that
this is just a draw okay check and black
can even play I can OOP sorry not this
probably this is possible that you can
just go back and we have fun check
perpetual coming um very difficult very
difficult situation um at the end he
took on before and I must say that this
is this gameis of amazing quality from a
technical point of view if you analyze
it with with the help of an engine you
will see that both sides played almost
perfectly there's only a very little
thing happening at the end of the game
other than that it is a fantastically
that's fantastic game d5 attacking the
Queen this was of course the idea black
gets the piece back immediately Queen f4
yeah to keep an eye on this pawn and
still have this in mind no black
recaptured the piece of course yeah here
why definitely wants to get the King out
of the middle and probably also most
importantly connect rooks to get Ruby
one in ocala took on c2 a good decision
main point is that this pawn is
controlling the one rookie one is not
possible white however has a strong
reply 95 again it's the best move
absolutely why should not play a passive
move like capturing Bishop f5 gives
black a good game yes even get this pawn
back most of the time 95 just strong
black cannot take this as Queen age 6 s
going to be the end of the game and the
night of course is doing a good job yet
allows this move it protects f6 and it's
just very well placed on d5 rookie 6
played by Carlton one of the it wasn't
the only move it was still however
probably the best one and now queen taxi
Falls plate which again seems best white
can try or can think about 97 check but
this is a move that a strong player is
very reluctant to play because black leg
of course we'll each give up the
exchange and in this situation we can
quickly see that black has two pawns for
the exchange and he even has chances to
keep this pawn by means of Bishop f5 and
the one very important thing is white
has completely given up the initiative
in this position he has exchanged his
active night and here only black can be
better if anyone okay Quincy for is
strong like now captured this is also
the best move and now the big point B 5
very very strong and needed to be seen
before hand this gains a super important
tempo for blacks development of course
why cannot take there is c6 yeah 97
check 27 and white loses a piece yeah an
otherwise it's just it's just a fork so
wyd cannot take he must play Quincy five
and now be should be seven this was
super important b5 we should be seven
all with temple
it's all working perfectly check now mvl
played this check again the best move
let's not really have any alternative
lights you can think of efore maybe as a
technical tactical idea but this is
unattractive at least them due to this
takes takes takes and you give up your
pawn em Jay the check is the best
movement King 2 h8 oops and queen takes
you to want to get rid of this pawn um
rook a 2 a-6 was played again logical we
want to get the pawn here um the next
move probably is the only slight slight
imprecision in in the whole game maybe
it's little a little one later but we're
talking about we're talking about trying
to play as well as an engine and they
both played fantastically here yeah rook
see one was no plate yeah lots of logic
behind that it seems that brooke d one
was a little bit more precise but this
was almost impossible to see beforehand
rook do you one um with the possible
continuation like this will be a 2d six
and now why term can afford a little
improving move if he wants like a three
yeah at black is in a state where he
cannot really do much else then then
trade everything off something like this
just to show you a a central variation
here why does a pawn up this needs to be
appreciated but this Bishop is just very
strong and why term should probably play
something like h4 h5 to get some attack
on the on the king um it's not easy to
to do anything anything actor fear like
this this idea because like
has this counter play but something like
this h4 seems to be about not equal
however this is we are talking about
very slight imprecision see Roxy one
rook f6 this is now forced and what they
did is they calculated this line Quincy
seven and now now it's black smooth and
exactly here is the only point where
cosplay maybe can be improved upon he
played the move Queen d2 and overlooked
something in the process a very little
detail better is Queen d3 which was very
very hard too hard to spot beforehand
this screen d3 possibility is by the way
the only reason why michela graphs rook
AC one was a little bit in precise yeah
bye-bye computer standards I mean um and
we see the reason it was totally inhuman
to see this beforehand um we should make
the comparison to Queen d2 played in the
game after Queen d2 it is in fact a
forced draw by by a perpetual check or
repetition difficult to see beforehand
can be a check King g7 jack check here i
canna check and King to age five this
was clear this line was was pretty clear
before hand check now the rook check g5
and in the game position here right can
force a draw and force the draw this was
played by yep takes g5 King takes Queen
g7 check root g6 check and we have this
this series of checks now like an player
5 White has check this way now to make
the draw there is no escaping this this
series of checks the difference to creed
III is if we now go all the way back
here if Queen d3 is played then there is
no draw simply because that here we can
go that far now I'm sorry of course to
h5 we look at the same the same thing
here check after this sorry black has
King edge form you must play this first
two to force g3 in a way catch me three
King takes Jess and Roop g6 check and
four check and this is now ending ending
badly there is no where no more check
every chance I sir the least possible
check and now this is threatened queen d
1 is threatened there is some there is a
bit a bit too much happening also on
White's King you cannot force the draw
amazingly enough in the game
continuation we need to see the
difference in the game continuation
check check check of the same line check
if King edge force plate here check
check check no f5 is no move the Queen
on d3 is covering covering this square a
very very little detail but this is a is
a difference what what would have
happened after Queen B 3 however why is
this better does not write have anything
else the problem is of course we have
this wretched Queen III and why probably
has to play this move from after this
and rook t6 we have reached an end game
where black is a pawn down but it's
definitely clear that black is the one
to play for win yes he has those ideas
rook t2 and the bishop is so much better
than the
the night on his 7 has absolutely no
square to go to it's very much dominated
here wyd needs to be very precise to to
hold a draw I couldn't really find a way
to to equality here um white can try to
be active with this but we should be
form is just strong rookie to coming I
don't see a way really to to clearly
hold this note that a move like this is
not not really helping very much this
kind of mafia is putting white really
under huge pressure where do you go now
you cannot go here for example as the
night oops sorry after jazz button and
tending rupee aid the night is just
trapped it's a very very unlucky piece
only seven I mean here white definitely
would have been would have been in some
some trouble but Carlton has stated
stated later that he had not seen the
consequences hear back check of a g5
correctly he made some if he said sums
he calculated something here that that
didn't didn't work out so at the end it
ended it ended with this this draw yeah
this was from a technical point of you
have a fantastically played game by both
both players nice piece of preparation
that at the end and it as it is so often
in a draw after a sharp struggle yeah I
hope you enjoyed the game's the second
round will bring a yeah modern modern
classic in a way that camera playing
black against thousand maybe neck and
where I can stop his his streak of
losses against the world champion we
will see i hope you enjoyed the video
thanks for watching